the
moment you get caught with the reading
with the bug of
reading and learning and you get
addicted to it
you have to know that your mind is going
to process stuff and the debate starts
happening here and it's forever it never
stops
he said you lose a little bit of
happiness when you go too much about
wanting to get certain questions
answered in life because it's never
going to end
it's forever he says so if you choose to
subscribe to wanting to become a
lifelong learner
be also ready to lose a part of that
happiness and freedom that you once had
when you didn't know everything now
you and i may say i wouldn't want to
live that life i mean what are you
talking about i don't want to be
controlled by other people i don't want
to be naive where i just
look at the media oh okay vote this way
okay okay do this well oh they're the
bad people oh you're right they're the
bad people i don't want to be that
person
but there's a part of it we're like you
know is that the life kind of i want to
live am i going to miss the freedom the
special small things that used to make
me be happy and i can't even enjoy the
small stuff that i used to
do you ever catch yourself asking oh
man maybe i'm in too deep of being this
worried genius and i've lost a bit of my
oh yes absolutely simple well i
certainly experienced that
when my health broke down and the reason
for that was that i
i not only did i get sick my life fell
apart because i couldn't do anything
that i used to be able to do
i couldn't listen to music i couldn't
read i couldn't write
i couldn't think i i i couldn't do any
of the because
everything that i had done was really
was um
complex and difficult all the things
that i engaged in
and what i did realize was that that
left me vulnerable on a certain front
because if i lost my
if i wasn't at in peak peak health let's
say
i wouldn't be able to do those things
and so i mean
that's why i'm walking now for example
you know i said i walk six miles a day
and i do that every day
it's very simple and i've played a lot
of ping pong and i've always liked that
but i never played that much but i like
that and
um there there is some utility and
having
things around that are rewarding and
good for you that are less complex
um i would say though that with regards
to the conflict between
let's say you know miserable wisdom
and happy ignorance is that there's
there's different forms of rewards to be
found in different places
you know you can think about this even
in terms of personality
one major personality dimension is
extroversion and the reason for that is
that we have
a pleasure circuit and how active that
is
varies between people that's what causes
variation in extroversion and
we generally equate happiness with the
activation of the circuitry that's
associated with extroversion and drugs
like cocaine and amphetamines activate
that circuit
but there's another personality
dimension which is openness
and openness is the creativity dimension
and there's pleasure to be derived from
that as well and then so that's
philosophical exploration and and
literary experience and
i suppose when you go to a movie you
experience a blend of those two things
especially if it's a rather complex
movie
so there's different forms of engagement
or pleasure to be found and some of them
are more akin to happiness and some of
them are more akin to
to meaning and sometimes they come into
conflict but
but i think all things considered they
they work best when they're
when they're working together and i i do
strive diligently to re
and i think that this has really been
brought home to me you know look i
couldn't sit down i literally couldn't
sit down for almost a year
and i so i lost the ability to sit down
i had fantasies
for hours of being able to sit by a
fireplace and just
not move because i had this condition
called akathesia which
is
i learned how how valuable it is to be
able to sit down and now when i sit down
and nothing is happening i i'm taking
stock of that and noticing what an
unbelievable gift that is and
it is really useful to maintain your
ability to see
what you have that you've taken for
granted because you can lose
you can lose everything you can lose
things you don't even know you have
i have no idea that you could ever lose
the ability just to sit down
but you can i wouldn't recommend it
so i'm more appreciative i would say of
of simpler things than i was
i'm more appreciative of other people
than i was
um i'm probably more grateful all things
considered than i was
and hopefully that will continue
developing
i have no contempt for happiness you
know i tell people don't pursue
happiness pursue
meaning and i think that's true but if
happiness comes along
it should be welcomed and if you're ever
somewhere where that's happening
you should notice it and and be grateful
for it and enjoy it and
that's for sure yeah do do you think
sometimes
uh the world sets an expectation of who
you are and your constant compliments oh
my gosh jordan let me tell you you
changed my life oh my gosh jordan
you don't even know what your book did
to me oh my gosh oh my gosh oh you have
no idea
because of you i'm doing it because of
you my marriage work because of you i
have better relation my dad because of
you i'm doing better than my mom because
of you
because of you because of you sometimes
that because of you
it's a little too much burden of because
of you it's like dude because of me
don't do [ __ ] like because of me just
let me be free for once like because of
you like
maybe i don't want you to say because of
you look go go live your life
you because of you you made the decision
i'm just writing a book do you ever feel
like
you don't want that standard and
expectation of
you know putting you on the pedestal
here and then
you have to almost walk on water where
you're not free do you ever
feel that kind of an obligation or no
that's not even something that crosses
your mind i feel that obligation all the
time
got it and i i have people around right
from the beginning of all this
i've i've talked to my friends and my
family all the time about what i'm doing
so that i don't
make a mistake you know so that we're
trying to stop me from making a mistake
so but i also especially when i'm
talking to people one-on-one i don't
want
see if you're a clinical psychologist
you don't want to steal people's
accomplishments from them which is
partly why you don't
you don't give advice exactly so maybe
someone is trying to decide whether they
should get married
and maybe you have an opinion but
probably you shouldn't
because as a psychologist let's say
because
except perhaps in extreme cases um
the person has to discover that what
they need to do for themselves
so that they can discover it again in
the future so they can learn to discover
things for themselves
and you don't want to give advice
because then if they do something good
you can take credit for it
and i i don't want to take credit for
for
um the accomplishments that people make
as a consequence of
what would you say putting the ideas
they encounter in my books
into practice they put them into
practice and good for them
and so when i meet people in the street
that's what i tell them you know it's
like okay you did this
this specific thing good for you and
you know i provided some impetus and i'm
happy about that and pleased to
to do that but i certainly don't want
the credit
and but i certainly i do feel the
obligation i think it is part of what
made me ill
i think it is because
you know as a psychologist i dealt with
people's innermost secrets for
decades and but it was kind of limited
right it was 13 people or so a week
maybe up to 20. which is still quite a
few people but
it's not it's not an inordinate number
of people it's a bounded
number of people and and then i had my
other work that i could
escape into let's say and and i wasn't
carrying it with me
the burden of of of of the lives of the
people that i was intertwined with
but then all of a sudden i started to
experience
that the the longing i suppose in some
sense
on a much greater scale
and that that's been
difficult to digest the misery
and and that that's so common
in people's lives and but even worse
than that that the degree to which it
requires
almost nothing to rectify it in an
important way
you know people there's many many people
who are
starving for a word of encouragement and
if you provide that
they they run with it and but that and
that's great but it also reveals this
this terrible unnecessary lack it's like
well why weren't they encouraged to
begin with
you know it and and that's a deep hole
to fall down
and you know because you can never stop
answering that question once you start
asking it
and you know it has something to do with
with the fundamental
difficulty that everyone who's human has
in
valuing their own existence because of
its
imperfections and and finitude and
it's a very complex question and then to
see that
played out thousands of times
these brief encounters i have with
people they're very intense
you know people tell me things in those
encounters that they don't tell anyone
else
or they tell very few people or maybe
they've never told anyone in their life
and
i can see too this young man stopped me
on the street the other day and he was
he was looking a bit beat up and he came
up and he said
he was very shy and he said well you
you know your lectures have been very
helpful and i said i asked him what his
name was and that usually helps people
set
set them at ease and then i said well
what what helped you
and he he was quite hesitant he didn't
exactly know how to formulate what he
was doing but i could see that
he was very scared to say
anything that he had done well
because his experience had been that
he'd never
been encouraged when he did something
well and so
you know you can really punish someone
if they come up to you and say they did
something good that was actually good
and then you punish them or ignore them
it really hurts them and that happens to
children all the time
and it certainly had happened to this
young man so he's very hesitant
to tell me what he had done that was
good and you know he told me and i
listened and i said look this is
as far as i'm concerned that what you
did was really good and he just lit up
you know it was
and that's great that he lit up but it's
terrible that
it hadn't happened to him before so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye
you